[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir revitaliser les sols c'est
effectivement un enjeu ça nécessite
quelques ruptures dans la pensée
revitaliser les sols ce n'est pas
quelque chose qui peut être accessoire
pour l'humanité c'est même quelque chose
qui ne qui est absolument indispensable
pour assurer sa survie
les sols ont des fonctionnalités
importantes
la première évidemment c'est d'assurer
l'alimentation humaine et on sait que
mieux en un gros système un éco système
fonctionne plus les aliments qui sont
produits sur ces soldats ont une densité
nutritionnelle élevée mais ils
remplissent aussi quelques autres
fonctions qui sont indispensables pour
l'humanité c'est la qualité de l'eau
puisque la plupart des volumes d'eau que
nous consommons passe à travers le sol
qui les filtres encore une fois mieux un
sol et revitalisé plus il est habité par
une microbiologie active plus les eaux
sont de qualité à la sortie
- elles contiennent de nitrates
également et de polluants il y a aussi
un autre élément qui est indispensable
et c'est l'une des fonctionnalités qui
est assurée par les sols c'est
directement et indirectement la qualité
de l'air que nous respirons y compris
celui qui est dans cette salle la
qualité de l'air c'est quoi c'est
d'abord sa teneur en oxygène 21%
d'oxygène c'est dû uniquement à la vie
ça a commencé avec quelques
cyanobactéries ça a été relayée par les
plantes vertes et ce sont elles qui ont
produit cette masse de d'oxygène que
nous respirons mais les sols ont si
cette capacité à stocker le carbone et
c'est le plus gros puits de carbone que
nous avons sur la planète et ses dents
évidemment dans cette sous cette optique
là que les sols ont réellement une
importance capitale
alors c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'affirme que l'homme est vivant quand
le sol et est vivant on a causé quelques
ruptures puisque c'est la thématique
quelques ruptures que nous sommes en
train d'observer la principale rupture
c'est justement l'augmentation des
températures moyennes au niveau du monde
on sait que depuis les années 70 80 au
milieu des années 70 on a observé une
augmentation significative des
températures moyennes
pour moi ça a été je dirais un
déclencheur j'étais à l'époque sur une
exploitation agricole celle de mon père
on a eu à connaître une sécheresse
vraiment très sévère qu'on n'avait
jamais connu jusque auparavant c'était
en 1976
tous les agriculteurs encore en activité
se souviennent parfaitement de cette
grande sécheresse
on pensait que c'était un événement
exceptionnel et puis finalement il s'est
répété on a eu plein d'épisodes depuis
2003 2006 etc
et c'était d'autant plus surprenant que
c'était en normandie et la normandie
n'étaient pas habitués à connaître ni
des sécheresses longue ni des canicules
mais il y avait aussi un autre événement
qui à ce moment-là a éveillé
complètement mon attention
deux jeunes agriculteurs c'est qu'il y
avait quelque chose qui ne collait pas
avec les modèles qu'on nous avait
proposé ce quelque chose qui ne collait
pas c'était le suivant nous avions dans
les vingt années précédentes doubler
notre production tripler la production
laitière tripler le nombre de bêtes et
en même temps on restitue est encore
plus de matériaux organiques plus de
fumier dans les sols l'us de résidus de
chaume et il y avait un postulat qui
était posée à la fois par l'enseignement
et la recherche
c'est que plus on en restituerait plus
on retrouverait de carbone dans les sols
on a fait des mesures 20 ans ou 30 ans
après ces pratiques la mise en oeuvre il
s'est avéré que finalement les taux de
carbone les taux de matière organique
était en train de s'effriter
donc c'est à ce moment là je me suis dit
il ya quelque chose qui ne colle pas il
ya quelque chose qui ne va pas il ya une
dimension qu'on n'a pas pris en compte
cette dimension qu'on n'a pas pris en
compte c'était tout simplement la
microbiologie des sols
il y à du vivant la terre ce ne sont pas
que des tableaux excel
il y à quelque chose d'autre au bout ce
qui nous fait dire aujourd'hui que on a
une grosse marge de progression et que
les sols pourrait vraisemblablement être
la solution
ils ont des capacités de stockage
important importante
et puis évidemment ce sont les
agriculteurs qui sont au premier plan
qui sont en tête de ligne ils sont
capables de mettre en oeuvre des choses
absolument extraordinaire les gens que
vous voyez sur l'écran sont des gens
avec lesquels je travaille en
partenariat proche et ils mettent déjà
en place des techniques d approche
complètement innovantes durables et qui
permettent de re stocker du carbone
alors comment se fait-il que nous ayons
perdu autant de fertilité comment nous
ayons extraits autant d'éléments du sol
eh bien ça se fait tout simplement après
une déforestation quand la forêt
disparaît d'un écosystème
on travaille le sol on met beaucoup de
choses en side savez des herbicides et
fongicides et insecticides qui ont
tendance à mettre à mal la microbiologie
des sols et on a cette chute qui s'opère
mais la bonne nouvelle dans tout cela
c'est que le processus est réversible et
quand on commence à mettre en oeuvre
certaines techniques culturales et puis
à utiliser des prébiotiques du sol on
observe à un changement immédiat dans la
microbiologie et à ce moment là on peut
regagner les niveaux antérieurs au moins
en partie
sinon en totalité il y a déjà beaucoup
d'agriculteurs qui met en oeuvre c'est
pratique ça consiste à réduire le
travail du sol
chaque fois qu'on le travail qu'on le
labour on peut le mettre à mal ça
consiste à mettre des couverts végétaux
à faire du semis direct et à restaurer
les fonctions essentielles qui sont
affaiblis par la mise en culture
le modèle c'est le climax c'est ça le
nouveau mode de pensée regardez qu'est
ce que la nature avait fait avant que
l'on
et friches et le climax sont nos régions
c'est tout simplement la forêt de
feuillus la forêt de feuillus comment
est-ce qu'elle fonctionne elle laisse
tomber au sol à partir de l'automne des
éléments qui sont matures des feuilles
des branches mortes
il y en microbiologie en tout cas une
population fongiques particulière qui
s'en occupe
elle est particulièrement efficace je
dirais même c'est la seule qui est
capable de le faire
elle est armée d'un point de vue ausy
matic pour attaquer ces molécules très
polymérisé très longue que sont le bois
et la lignine et ils font leur travail
alors s'il sait cette flore fongiques a
une telle importance
et elle a été tellement abîmée par nos
pratiques jusqu alors avec les
fongicides entre autres mais aussi le
travail du sol c'est que les champignons
ont une capacité importante à stocker du
carbone quand ils le valent quand il
transforme de la matière organique
il en stock 50% et il n'en rejette que
50 % dans l'atmosphère si on a une
microflore déséquilibré à base de
bactéries on va en rejeter 85% dans
l'atmosphère et non stockés que 15%
donc là voilà l'explication de 1976 qui
était une rupture dans la pensée pour
moi ces mécanismes là on est capable
aujourd'hui de les générer grâce à
l'avancée de la science grâce à des
formules que j'ai pu mettre au point
on sait qu'on peut refaire apparaître
ces champignons dans les champs et la
bonne nouvelle toujours c'est que non
seulement c'est un espoir mais c'est un
espoir qui se réalise on a mesuré des
augmentations moyennes jusqu'à 3% de
carbone en plus dans les sols à travers
ces pratiques là 3% cet énorme puisque
la coop 21 qui se tenait en 2015 avait
fixé comme objectif de fixer 4 pour
mille c'est-à-dire 0,4 pour cent pour
arriver à compenser intégralement le co2
le gaz carbonique qui est produit par la
combustion des fossiles des carburants
fossiles
donc dans les exemples que nous avons
pris les expérimentations que nous avons
fait valider par unis lasalle beauvais
par des laboratoires comme sélestat lab
c'est qu'on peut aller bien au delà
alors il ne faut pas s'emballer parce
qu'on l'a fait dans des situations où
les sols étaient très dégradés et où le
delta le potentiel de récupération de
stockage était important sur des
prairies il sera bien inférieur mais
cela veut dire que en moyenne 4 pour
mille cette atteignable alors le
deuxième volet sur le climax et c'est
l'autre grande idée que je veux vous
exposer ce soir c'est que le climax a
une particularité c'est aussi ce dans
son cycle de végétation
les images que vous voyez derrière moi
sans aucun doute vous disent quelque
chose quand on traverse la france au
mois de juillet au mois d'août au mois
de septembre
ça ressemble à ça alors c'est
sympathique il ya des moutons c'est bio
on ne met pas de poison
mais ce n'est pas pour autant si
vertueux que ça pourquoi pas ce qu'on
voit en arrière plan une végétation qui
est en train la végétation climatique
c'est-à-dire les arbres qui est en train
de puiser de l'eau en profondeur qui est
en train de fabriquer de la matière
sèche qui est en train de capter du gaz
carbonique et de rejeter de l'oxygène
alors qu'on a des chants qui sont comme
des paillassons qui n'ont plus du taux
d'activité qui sont exposés aux rayons
du soleil qui ont une température en
moyenne de 15 degrés supérieures et qui
finalement sont une véritable
catastrophe écologique
donc il y a quelque chose à faire
évidemment dans ce domaine là et c'est
ça peut être amplifiée par les pratiques
agricoles et entre autres le surpâturage
le surpâturage ils concernent au moins
les trois quarts des surfaces en herbe
sur la planète
on a au moins deux milliards d'hectares
sur les cinq qui sont des pâturages où
le régime cochon en train de décrire est
celui qui est mis en place et on peut
l'amplifier tout simplement par une
gestion désastreuse je vais l'appeler
des as
heureuse des pâturages parce que si on
laisse sur pâturer la plante l'herbe à
une surface de photosynthèse des
panneaux photovoltaïques qui sont
tellement réduit qu'elle ne peut plus
alimenter un enracinement profond il y à
une mortalité racinaire l'enracinement
se réduit comme une peau de chagrin et
on arrive à ce paradoxe là que même
l'humidité qui est en profondeur on ne
peut plus aller la chercher
laplante n'a plus les moyens d'aller la
chercher donc évidemment il y a quelque
chose à faire
on peut appliquer d'autres méthodes et
on voit ici dans une même région dans
une même période de l'année avec des
sols complètement identique
d'un côté une végétation complètement
active et puis de l'autre un sol qui est
complètement brun est biologiquement
physiologiquement coisy mort alors ce
modèle là on peut ce microclimat là on
peut le reproduire avec des plantes
cultivées comme le maïs on va retrouver
exactement la même atmosphère et la même
protection de la faune de la microfaune
de la microbiologie en surface on va pas
être exposés directement au soleil on va
pomper les nitrates pendant toute la
période où il ya à la fois de la chaleur
et de l'humidité
on va éviter la pollution des nappes la
betterave est deux à des fonctionnements
absolument identique mais il y a aussi
le soja la luzerne et c'est qu'ils sont
capables de reproduire ces modèles là la
betterave à quelque chose de puissant
c'est que même si elle souffre d'une
sécheresse pendant deux mois
elle est capable de récupérer dès la
première pluie donc c'est en cela que je
dis qu'elle est intelligente puisque
elle sait s'adapter à son environnement
alors ça une importance aussi le fait
d'entretenir un système copiant ou le
climax c'est à dire cette végétation
naturelle c'est que lorsque l'on a de la
végétation qui est très active pendant
toute la saison estivale
on se donne la possibilité
d'évapotranspiration envoyé de la vapeur
d'eau dans l'atmosphère donc de
fabriquer des nuages
n'importe quelle plante est capable
d'évaporer d'évapotranspiration entre
250 et 500 millimètres d'eau ses 2500 à
5000 mètres cubes d'eau par hectare
c'est absolument colossal et là où le
monde est merveilleux le monde du
végétal et merveilleux l'écosystème est
merveilleux c'est que on a la
possibilité en plus de provoquer la
chute de la pluie il suffit pas de faire
des nuages
encore faut-il qu'il pleuve et bien la
végétation a ce pouvoir là parce que ses
feuilles sont couvertes de milliards de
bactéries qui lors d'un coup de vent
d'orage va les emmener dans les couches
atmosphériques qui contiennent
l'humidité de l'air et ses minuscules
bactéries vont être alors des noyaux de
nucléation autour desquels vont
s'agréger les microgouttelettes et quand
la masse critique va être atteinte des
masses et la pluie elles vont tomber ces
micro gouttelettes ça va tomber c'est la
pluie donc c'est un cycle évidemment
qu'il vaut mieux entretenir
donc chaque fois que vous voyez des
champs complètement débarrassée de toute
végétation active dites vous que même si
ça répond à un cahier des charges
il ya quelque chose qui ne tourne pas
rond et on n'est pas en train
d'entretenir le l'écosystème donc là
quand on a du maïs irrigué et qu'on va
chercher simplement de l'eau à 20 ou 30
mètres de profondeur
ça peut être quelquefois vertueux parce
qu'on est en train de se substituer en
quelque sorte à l'écosystème tels qu'ils
étaient construits initialement quand on
prive un écosystème de l'arbre on
l'empêchent cet écosystème d'aller
chercher de l'eau en profondeur et c'est
une responsabilité morale de l'homme par
son défrichage d'apporter cette aide à
lasson agrosystèmes c'est-à-dire qu'ils
on a une obligation en tant qu'humain de
compenser les fonctions on a
complètement réduite voire complètement
supprimée
alors pour conclure la revit la
revitalisation des sols c'est important
d'abord à travers deux ou trois
mécanismes qui sont les suivants d'abord
relancer le cycle des minéraux et de
l'eau il y à des endroits où la
végétation naturelle est capable d'aller
cherche déchets des minéraux très en
profondeur
je connais des lieux où il y à des
arbres qui vont chercher du calcium
au delà des 20 ou 30 mètres d'alluvions
acide et ça permet de ramener en surface
du calcium dans ces circonstances là
c'est qu'une obligation d'apporter du
calcium lot de le même certains sols ne
sont pas capables de stocker il faut
qu'on puisse faire des réserves
collinaires par exemple pour apporter
cette eau qui pourrait faire défaut à un
moment donné
stocker le carbone dans les sols on l'a
compris c'est hyper important parce que
de cet honneur du carbone dans le sol va
dépendre le climat futur
on connaît la solution c'est de
restituer des matériaux les plus matures
possibilit possible au sol et grâce à
des bio stimulant des prébiotiques on
arrive à réveiller toutes ces grandes
familles fongiques ils font un travail
extraordinaire et puis enfin la
synchronisation climatique c'est-à-dire
de produire sous nos climats un minimum
de végétation pendant tout l'été
ça c'est quelque chose qui est important
alors ça réclame quelques qualités pour
mettre tout cela en oeuvre d'abord de la
modestie parce que l'homme n'est pas en
haut de la pyramide du vivant il est
bien dedans
il est pas tout en haut il ne trône pas
là ça c'est une absolue certitude donc
faut qu'il soit assez modeste pour aller
voir qu'est ce qui se passe dans les
écosystèmes naturels
ensuite il faut de la générosité de la
générosité parce que tout ce qu'on met
en oeuvre a une incidence sur le tout
sur la planète entière et l'agriculteur
qui à certaines pratiques sur son sol on
l'a vu sur le climat régional mais aussi
sur le climat mondial
il peut avoir des incidences très très
forte
ça nécessite donc de se comporter je
veux dire de manière responsable
enfin de l'optimisme est pas de
l'optimisme béat de l'optimisme qui
pousse à l'action
et évidemment on a tous quelque chose à
faire dans ce domaine là y compris sur
les sols et ce sont les agriculteurs qui
sont concernés mais aussi vous tous dans
la salle et ceux qui m'écoutent à
travers les réseaux sociaux pour lancer
évidemment les bons messages dans le
public et dans l'inconscient collectif
et puis enfin et je vais dire un merci
mais pas en mots propres non simplement
au nom des huit milliards d'hommes haut
niveau au nom du climat et au nom de la
terre pour qu'on mette un tout petit peu
certaines de ces idées là en oeuvre
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]